Tonight, Beyonce
actively working to convert Americans
to paganism.
Yeah, that's just one of the bizarre,
often controversial statements
from the head of the Michigan GOP.
Statements uncovered by CNN file.
Christina, Karamo
most recently faced
harsh backlash
for defending this highly offensive tweet
comparing gun control to the Holocaust.
Well, now seeing the tape,
Al has uncovered
a long history of eyebrow
raising comments,
including this one about Beyonce.
She's really targeting
trying to target black people
into embracing paganism.
And one of the really interesting things
is that her husband, Jay-Z, is
many people have said as a Satanist,
I believe it to be true
I mean, I don't know how you answer that.
Right.
OUTFRONT now, the senior
editor of the
K File, Ed
Kaczynski, and Harry Enten,
who has some eye opening numbers
on how election deniers like
Christina Cuomo are faring with voters.
So let's start with you
in terms of what you uncovered.
I heard that
Beyonce, Jay-Z, one moment
and I'm just left speechless.
What else did you find in
terms of these past
outlandish statements?
So grumbles sort of
came onto the scene in 20, 20
when she was she was a poll watcher
and she claimed
there was fraud in Detroit.
People probably remember
Trump was really
making many of these poll watchers
who made these false allegations of fraud
almost like celebrities
And she parlays this into running
for Michigan secretary of state in 2022
she loses badly.
But prior to this in 2020
she had this podcast where she posted
videos made comments.
And I just want to
run through for our viewers
just some of the things
that she said here she accused Beyonce.
Jay-Z Ariana
Grande and Billie
Eilish of being tools of Satan
that the sexual revolution
was a
well orchestrated
and thought out plan by Satan
said black lives
matter was nothing
but Marxism and Satanism in blackface
accused black lives
matter leaders of being Marxist witches
said she doesn't believe in vaccines
called abortion child sacrifice and said
acceptance of LGBTQ Americans
and gay American
transgender Americans
would eventually lead
to the normalization of pedophilia.
I want people to listen to also
this clip here where she suggests that
demonic possession is transferred
via sexual intercourse
if a person has demonic possession.
And not going to sound really crazy, me
saying that for something like what?
But having intimate relationships
with people who are demonically possessed
or oppressed,
I strongly believe
that a person opens themselves
up to possession.
Demonic possession is real
Wow.
And I just I mean, just leaves
it leaves me speechless to hear the
I mean,
she says this is what she believes,
but this is a woman who's now
the head of the Republican Party state.
Right. And it's interesting.
Why is this important?
Well, it's very important
to Republicans in Michigan
because this is a state that Republicans,
you know,
they have
they plan
this is a state
that recently had a Republican governor.
This is a state
that Donald Trump won in 2016.
But last cycle,
which they're running
against the backdrop
of an unpopular Democratic president.
They lost the top three seats.
They lost the governor,
attorney general, secretary of state.
Her loss was the most lopsided one
14 points.
And what is the state party
chair supposed to do?
They're supposed to do get out the vote.
They're supposed to help fundraise
they're supposed to help local candidate.
And there are,
you know,
serious questions
if somebody who's made these comments
as an activist
is going to be able to do that job
effective
We did
obviously reach out to her
before we did the story
and we didn't we didn't hear back yet,
which I think you lay out there,
why it's so important
that we pay attention to these comments.
So, Harry, when we look at this,
she is a prominent
election denier, as we know.
As Andrew pointed out,
she lost that state race in 20, 22
What are the numbers
tell us about
how election denial played with voters.
It didn't it play quite poorly, right.
You know,
Andrew was kind of pointing it out.
We all went into this midterm election.
A lot of folks like me
you saw President Joe Biden's approval
rating in the low 40 say
Republicans are going to do very well
because there's normally a backlash
against some popular presidents
but they didn't. Why?
Well look at the electoral penalty
that voters assign
to those who believe
in election denialism.
Five points in the margin,
five points in the margin
in major statewide 2022 races.
And while five points
may not seem like a lot,
you know in states
like Michigan, in states
like Arizona, states
like Georgia,
close states
that five points can make
all the difference in the world.
And specifically,
if you're talking about the Senate.
Right.
Said it was super important, as we know.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
And, you know,
our exit
polls had an interesting question
they basically rated the Democratic
and Republican candidates said.
Do you view them as too extreme?
And what happened in those races?
It turns out in the vast
majority of the competitive races,
more voters
in those key battleground states said
that the Republican candidates
were too extreme as compared
to the Democratic candidates.
So the fact is,
this is not just something
that we just see in the polling data.
It's something we see
in the real election data.
Election denialism, simply put,
does not play with the American public.
There's a lot of talk
about the impact of Donald Trump
on the candidate he endorsed in 20, 24.
But as we look ahead to 2022
to 2022 rather
as we look ahead to 2024
he's a candidate
leading in the polls right now
among Republicans.
What effect has this base
first strategy of his
had in the election denialism
on how the general public sees him.
Yeah something that's so interesting
you know when you look back on 2016
I think a lot of people forget
that more voters actually vote
said that
Hillary said that Donald Trump
was moderate than Hillary Clinton
look at the percentage of voters
or Americans
adults at large
who said that Trump was very conservative
back in 2016. Look at that.
It was only about 20% among those
who had an opinion
Look at it now it's over 50%.
So the fact is
Trump's
statements have certainly had an impact
and not in a good way.
Voters are now much more likely to view
him as extreme.